hey guys so today we're gonna talk about
Hashimoto's okay this is an autoimmune
condition hypothyroid condition there's
another autoimmune related to the
thyroid it called Graves and that would
be a hyper thyroid so that speeds things
up too fast hypo it's too slow so I'm
gonna kind of walk you through some
pieces of this puzzle an autoimmune
condition is where your immune system
your own body's immune system is
generating cells that are attacking
itself called antibodies anti against
the body okay and it's kind of weird
that it'll do that but it does that and
pretty much any tissue in the body you
can have an autoimmune to any tissue the
nervous system the connective tissue
even snow via fluid in the joints but as
far as the thyroid goes there's the most
common antibody that that's involved in
Hashimoto's is something called anti TPL
antibodies what does that mean basically
it's anti-thyroid peroxidase now what is
the peroxidase that's just an enzyme so
thyroid peroxidase which is TPO as an
enzyme that works with hydrogen peroxide
to basically make thyroid hormones so
it's some chemical in the thyroid that's
involved in making the thyroid hormone
it's basically you can take the dietary
iodine and then it converts it to the
iodine that's necessary to make the
thyroid hormone because you have like t3
and t4 this the 4 and the 3
represent the number of iodine molecules
in that protein in that hormone so to do
that you need this chemical and this
chemical together now they really don't
know exactly what causes this problem
but we know it's a problem within the
immune system we know that somehow it
could be involved in your body's
dropping to defense of the immune system
because many these conditions occur
right after a stress event so you have
this adrenal connection which also
controls the immune system and then you
have the immune Drina connection so that
could be a link but when you have an
autoimmune condition we do have excess
hydrogen peroxide floating around and if
you you may have some of this in your
cupboard like this little this bottle of
hydrogen peroxide that you use if you
cut yourself to sterilize it okay to
disinfect because it's a very powerful
oxidant so it kind of bubbles and cleans
bacteria kills bacteria so how did you /
oxide if it's in the body at higher
levels it can actually create oxidative
stress or damage so one thing we want to
do is you want to kind of remove the
excess amount of this right here and
that's what I'm going to talk about
because we want to increase our immune
defenses we want to increase the
antioxidant Network that's going to
actually fight and neutralize the
oxidant so we start up with selenium
selenium is a very powerful antioxidant
it's a trace mineral that is very
helpful in making thyroid hormones and
also helping the conversion from the
inactive to the active form zinc is
another powerful antioxidant and there's
one more that has a very long name s
acetyl l al very important antioxidant
that will help clear out the excess
amount of hydrogen peroxide so if I
personally had Hashimoto's these are
some of the remedies that I would take
to support that condition so we can
actually remove some of the excess
hydrogen peroxide because that can
create more damage and I would focus
also on just getting my body healthier
and healthier and definitely include in
a minute fasting because anytime you do
prolong in a minute fasting but let's
say you do it once a month or once every
other month you are going to drop
inflammation your gonna help the immune
system you are going to enhance the
immune function alright thanks for
watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos